εξέληξης κακοήθειας μετάλλαξης κυτάρωσ κακοήθεια με την ελικία ανεβαίνει επομένος έχουμε περίπου τα ιδι αποσωστά
μόνομετα αναλύσει κάποιος με την με το προσδόκιμο ζωής με την επιβίωσητων ανθρώπων βλεπούμε ότι
είναι κάτι τοοποίον έπρεπε να αναμένεται για τρέ θεωρείται είναι θεμα κουλτούρας στον αποβάλουμε κάποσακύπρια
να πούμε αυτός έχει καρκίνο δηλαδή να τοπάρουμε ότι είναι άλλη μια ασθενη και θα
ξεπεράστει είναι θεμα κουλτού να δατί βλέπεις ότι όταν ο άλλος έχε αυτή την αρρωστια
ο γύρο ο κόσμος λέε αυτός έχει καριοείναι είναι ναι θεμα κουλτούρας αυτό μπορεί να
αλλά επιστεύφύσικα αλλάσει ίδη έχει αλλάξει σημαντικά τα τηλευταία χρόνια η καταρχάς αυτή η οποί
μετα από διάγνωση καρκίνο είνα πλέονγίς είναι ένας σημαντικός αριθμός μέσα στην κοινωνία μας ακαι
αυτό μας δημειουργεί επίσης την εντύπωση ότι η κοίταξε ο καρκίνωση είναι πολύ πιο συχνώς
ι επιζόνοταις του καρκίνου είναι ακόμε περισότερο σήμερα πενήνται της εκατό περίπου με τη διάγνωση
του καρκίνο έχουν τη δυνατότα της ίασης και ανεβαίνονται πό σοστα υπάρχουν ο καρκίνος το
προστά τη φτυχώς υπάρχει τοποίεσε με την έγγειρη διάγνωση όχι μόνον η επιβίωση οχιμονονίας η
αλλά και υπιότητα ζωής ανάλση είναι σημαντικό και έχουμε τρομερά επιτέύομετα σε αυτό όπως και
τούμαστο με την πρόληψη όλα τα πράγματα εξελίσονται θετικά θέλει χρόνο θέλει όμως και υποστήρηξη
από τους